opengl
part 4. today we're going to talk about
modernizing this a little bit we're
going to go up to a newer version of
opengl
we're going to be looking at opengl 4.3
and newer
so we're going to depreciate some of
those old
old things we're going to start doing
things in a new way mainly what we're
going to do today
is we're going to talk about how to
check your version and check everything
to make sure you're on this more modern
version because we're going to be
getting
deep into shaders and a lot of the
shader stuff works in a certain
way if you're trying to do it the old
way it's just not going to work so
that's uh what we're going to do very
first here and we're also going to talk
about the new way
to upload your attributes up to your
shader
with this new 4.3 and later
and we're also going to talk about
getting a list of all your attributes on
your shader
so that's going to be pretty much what
this whole episode is all about and
we'll continue on with a few more basics
next video
and then after that we should start
being able to do some fancy stuff with
shaders
and as long as you follow along you
should be able to
basically learn all about shaders and do
super cool stuff with them and this
translates pretty well to vulcan and
directx as well because
even if you write shaders and glsl which
is what we're going to be using here
you can compile those into other types
so
yeah buckle up let's just jump right
into it
now of course this code is up on github
and there's going to be quite a few
changes since the last episode so let's
talk about what we're going to do
first we're going to set this core
profile of opengl which basically means
we're not going to use any backwards
compatible uh depreciated stuff and
that's what this four is compat means as
well
true and we're just targeting 4.3 you
can go newer you can go
all the way up to 4.6 if you want all
this stuff should work but if you start
going older
it's not going to work so that's the
whole point of this print opengl
info here we want to make sure we're on
the latest version now really since i
have like a little logger class i
probably should just log it but i didn't
i just
printed it to console for now so maybe
i'll do that later or someone wants to
make the change
up on github i'll give you a little
shout out in the next video for making
those changes
to log that instead also the logger
needs a date stamp so if anyone like
wants to mess with that
feel free i'm just not doing it because
i'm looking at other stuff and
i don't want to get distracted by
non-opengl stuff basically
now to print this opengl stuff you do
have to do this glad load proc thing
first like if you try to do this before
you context your window
it won't work so just keep that in mind
so all this function does
is it calls these gl with these geo get
string
functions with these enums to ask you
what to get or tell it what to get
so we're going to get the string a
string of the vendor and this glu byte
is just a
unsigned character by basically it's
basically a string
if you're not too familiar with what all
that is so
or a const care array which is basically
a string
all right so we're going to look at the
vendor the renderer
what version we're on and you can also
look at the version
with uh integers too with get integer
and also we want to look at the shading
language so if we go ahead and run this
we'll see what it gets here
so this is just something you want to be
able to do as you can see i changed the
triangle we'll get to that in a little
bit
but we're just looking at these lines
right here
so the vendor it says nvidia corporation
because i have an nvidia graphics card
and nvidia drivers
the get renderer it tells us what
graphics card we're using
how it's plugged in and the instruction
set
and the version is it's going to say the
version
of opengl and our video card and our
graphics driver
so the stuff can all be relevant for
when you're troubleshooting
and we can also grab those with the
integer just the version so
you might want the integers for doing a
comparison to say if you want your
program to yell at somebody and say hey
update or something you know it's easier
to compare the integers rather than a
string so that's always handy
and last the shading language so the
shading language
uh it basically tells us what version
4.3
now these aren't necessarily the same
but starting with i think version
opengl 3.3 and later these started
matching up so the version
and the shading language are going to be
the same but it also says
what we're compiling with because you
know of course your shader is compiled
and put on the graphics card your shader
is essentially
a program that runs on the graphic card
so usually when you program you
programmed for to run on your cpu
and ram well shader programs run on your
gpu
so that's the big difference and they're
all about doing the massive
multi-threaded stuff and
doing cool stuff with pixels and making
your games look sweet and all that or
whatever you're doing
so it just tells us the nvidia via cg
compiler and you can go google cg
compiler if you wonder what it is
basically the shader compiler from
nvidia
okay so that's pretty much it for
checking the info you just use these
functions
make sure you got the right stuff and if
you're questioning or running into
confusing things
all right now let's take a look at the
new modern way to upload
your vertices now what i mean by all
that because that probably sounds like a
mouthful of confusing stuff if you've
never heard that before
is basically well you have your shader
program here
and ours are right here now the shader
it starts out as a lump of text code
just like any other
program does but
this is a well it's just a string
that we compile into a program and put
it up on
the video card so
here it is we have some inputs of a
vertice position and a vertices color so
these do work in a pipeline
and this vertex shader is the very first
one there are a bunch of others which we
will get into later
but we're going to keep it super simple
right now because i don't want to
get sidetracked too much it makes it too
confusing but it goes from the vertex
shader
and then it goes to the fragment shader
also called a pixel shader
this is what determines what color each
pixel on your screen or window
is so based on the position in the color
we do whatever calculations we need
here we're just going to assign so they
pass through these are essentially
called a pass through in this case
and uh yeah then at the end here we just
say our color equals that fragment color
so let's move forward a little bit we
got the load shader in there that is
exactly the same as it was before
from the last episode no changes to the
load shader
yeah but the big change we do have here
is the way we're doing
our our data we're still put we're still
starting them out as an array
just a float array because that's really
simple and you can see we have nine
locations here for the positions which
are just
three dots like there's there's one of
the points there's one points points
dots
you know i'm kind of interchanging the
words there's the other one
so that's just locations on a screen to
make a triangle
and color data these correlate with each
uh point here like this one it's going
to line up here and be red
this one is going to line up here and be
green and this one
and it's going to be blue and then we're
going to still use that element buffer
array because it's faster it's very
simple we just want the three
points of the triangle all right now
here's where the big change comes in
in this upload mesh function so
now we are going to pass it the position
data the color data
the size of those arrays which we're
using this macro for
um so this is kind of an old well i
don't know if you want to call it macro
call
what would it be i don't know just a
calculation
so the size of position data is going to
give you the entire size of this full
array which is going to be 9 floats
so 9 times whatever and then divide it
by the size of
one of those floats or position 0 so
divided by the size of the first one
and basically what this ends up turning
into is the size of the array
or in this case 9. so we just want to
tell how many
because when we pass these to the
function all it is
is a pointer to the very start of the
array it doesn't necessarily know what
size it is so we've got to pass it to
size 2.
and we're doing the same thing with the
elements and also passing the size of
the elements and the point of doing it
this way
is if this changes or grows or shrinks
then this function still passes in
the proper size kind of just a
c thing all right so let's go to this
function and take a look at our new way
of doing it
there's our old way i'm leaving it in
here you can make a
vector full of the vertices and just
call it a mesh and upload it the old way
but the old way has a few things that
are a little confusing or hard to
understand
mainly when we do this gl vertex
trig pointer thing it combines the
functionality of a couple things it's
it's giving multiple pieces of info in
one function
so in this new way of doing it we're
kind of just separating it out
because rather than buffer the data of a
mesh all at once
which if we look at this vertex it is
the position and color
all in basically one array
so yeah we can do that we can buffer it
all at once and then
say and do the offset and stride thing
that i may have
talked about last episode but instead of
that
we're going to do it the new modern way
which they recommend doing now because
it's supposed to be a little bit more
clear and i would agree it's a bit more
clear
so it's just this function i'm going to
walk through it a little i'm going to
kind of summarize i'm not going to get
into a ton of detail
but basically now for every
different array you pass in like we're
having the vertices and the colors here
you create a separate vbo for it in this
case we're starting out with a main
array of vbos and there are reasons for
that basically when we go to delete them
at some point
you can just pass in this whole thing at
once but
as you upload them you want to do them
one at a time so we're going to generate
two vbo handles we're going to also
start calling them handles because that
seems to be what a lot of people call
them and it makes sense
they are just unsigned integers that say
hey this is the position of it
up on the shader so it's kind of a
handle to access it
all right so we generate two of these
because we know we need one of them for
the verts
and one of them for the colors so then
we also do
this thing we make another unsigned ant
and we call it
we give it a logical name position
buffer handle and we say
it is the first element in these handles
and we do the same thing
with the color for the next one and then
we're going to go ahead and
bind our new buffer for the position as
an array buffer and buffer the data
of just the verts and this is where we
need that size of because
we do say well there's the data for the
verts and it's a pointer
so as i was talking about pointers this
pointer here
is just a pointer to the start of that
array so it does need to know what size
with this v count
so this needs to know how much to buffer
and it's going to be nine
times the size of a float so that should
buffer the correct amount of data
and of course static draw because it's
not going to be changed
all right we do the same thing for the
color we bind the color buffer buffer
handle and upload it as well and it's
the same size because each one
correlates so that's why we only need to
do this recount once because these are
always going to be the same size in our
case and going forward we'll change
things and update it as we need to
all right so these buffer objects
are not really accessible because
they they need to be organized within
a vertex array object which is what
we're going to set up next
so we set up this we generate one vertex
array now this is sort of like
just think of it as a box that contains
all the vbos
plus the element so it's like all the
data we need for this particular mesh
is going to be stored within this
because otherwise these are just all
separate
so we need to group them together
basically with this vao
okay so we generate one and then we bind
it
and opengl is smart enough to know what
it is because some of this stuff is just
assumed like
once you bind this vertex array and then
you enable position zero and
enable position one with this vertex
of trip array it's going to be looking
for these these buffer
arrays that we made earlier but we
haven't said where they're at yet we've
just
enabled zero and one well the handles
are called
zero and one that's really just a
position in these
so we'll get to that here so then we do
a bind vertex array zero
and it is here's where it figures out
which one it is
so we gotta enable it i think you can do
this enable later like you could do it
after
but i like doing it before that's how
most people seem to do it
and we're going to go ahead and give it
the info and needs about it
so it's uh basically this is how large
each element is right there
so size of a float times three because
each point is an xyz
which is three points and this is
the position i believe this is the
buffer name this is where it starts in
the data
on that array i believe and same with
the color
and then next up we do
this vertex a trib format and vertex
attrib
binding so this is kind of where it gets
separated where it's different than this
pointer thing
it's it's just all of this here so we
tell what format it is
we once again the location how big it is
it's uh
three elements and then float whether
it's normalized and i can't remember
what this last one is but it's pretty
much
always going to be zero in our case and
then this binding now this binding is a
new thing that we never used before
but it's basically how you map it to the
location and the shader
because before this was kind of just
assumed
with these and that's all you had there
was nothing really saying
well let's let's take a look at our
source here put this over here
let's look at our shader real quick so
we have location 0 and location 1.
so before this was basically just kind
of assumed that they would line up
correctly but not necessarily guaranteed
now we can specifically say
okay bind the zero to the zero
so it will literally bind this verb
position to the
zero here which is also a verb position
but you can map these however you want
you can map it to three or four or
whatever
so you can do it's kind of special stuff
there but we're just keeping them lined
up because that's nice
but it's supposed to make it more clear
and we do the same thing with the float
we map one to one here so it lines up
here
so it lines up from like you know from
here
to here all the ones go into one hope
that makes sense i know it's kind of a
little bit to wrap your head around once
you do it a few times and just
just kind of make sure it lines up and
those are all the same as you go through
and walk through it it'll work
then we're just going to find our
elements this is all the same as before
we just want to get those in the vao as
well now one thing i notice is you can't
delete your
your buffers for the vbo and elements
because really we're only going to
return the bao that's the only one we
need to keep
and the element size because we need to
iterate through all those when we draw
so that's why we're returning a draw
details with vao and elements
but yeah when you delete these you have
some errors whereas before
we would delete them at the end and it
was fine so i'm not entirely sure why
that is but
yeah just don't delete them it's the
point there
all right and that's the big change
there
so i believe there was just one more
thing we wanted to cover and that was
getting a list of these attribute arrays
so you have your shader here
you have all this stuff but once it's
like pushed up to your graphics card and
your
program is running you don't necessarily
have an easy way
of seeing these you can go look at your
shader and kind of try to take a look at
it
but there is actually a way to get them
with the opengl stuff
and so we're going to talk about that
real quick because that's what we're
going to do
and that is uh let's go scroll down here
we do it right here i have i built a
query a trib
arrays function or query of trips
all right so the only thing this is
going to need to know to query
is the vao and we have that in our
details vector which we
populated when we did the whole upload
thing so we passed it that now let's
take a look at this function
so it needs to handle the vao handle
should probably name it
that because it'd be a little more clear
like v-a-o
handle ah forget it you guys will figure
it out all right
so
to do this you use gl get program
interface iv which is an integer virtual
basically a pointer to a integer so
that's why we reference
because that turns it into a pointer and
program input
is the vertex shader inputs
it's very specifically the very first
part of the shader inputs
so it's going to line up with these two
here
that's what we're looking for there's
other things you can check here there's
other gl
enums you can go look up this function
believe i have it up already actually
right here uh yeah gl
get program uh
resource or skip program interface
so i'm actually looking at the wrong one
here but if we just do a google search
of it and find it there
there it is and you can see what it
takes you can see all the stuff about it
and you also notice uh the versions
yeah you'll see that it's version 4.3
and later that's another reason we need
to make sure we're on the right version
because if we're using this kind of
stuff
we need to make sure we're on the wrong
right version and same with this get
program resource name which we'll use
here
in a second as well it's 4.3 and later
okay so basically active resources ones
are actually in use
store how many all right and then we
need to make a
array of properties this is going to be
passed in to get program resource
later because basically iterates through
and returns what you ask for
it wants an array of properties because
you can basically ask for whatever you
want we're going to ask for the name
length the type and the location
because later we're going to get the
resource name and we need to know this
name length so we know what size to make
our character buffer
when we grab that and then we're just
going to print it out to the console
ideally you might actually log this or
something but console's going to work on
our case you could also print this to
your screen and a debug if you're using
some kind of interfacing thing
or putting text on your screen
not doing that yet we might do that at
some point and this get type string
oh yeah i guess i kind of skipped over
this i'll go back a little bit elsa so
this properties you also want to store
the results which are integers and it
has to be the same size we're getting
three properties
so we need an array of size three to
store those properties for what it gets
and those are just
integers um
which are basically end up being enums i
believe
that you have to sort out at least some
of them do like the name length is
obviously an integer which is the length
of the name
the type which is going to be in the
next slot is going to be
i believe it's going to be an enum so
we're going to actually check that
with this function here this get type
string and return the actual
type so if it ends up being what should
be a vect3 in our case so we should
return a vector3 string that way when we
print it out later
right here it should say vect3
and there's the name we populate the
name with this get program resource name
from the input we're going to pass it
all the stuff give it the name to fill
out
and you can always go google these if
you want to know more about these
functions
and of course at the end we are deleting
this
name or pointer array that way it
doesn't
leak memory so i actually had trouble
getting this to work correctly
it should say basically location 0 vert
pause vect3 and then location 1 for
color back 3 but for some reason in my
case it just
doesn't seem to work i get 2
and then true and it also says the total
attributes is 1 which it's
actually 2 but it does seem to work
correctly so i'm not sure why that
is i was banging my head against the
wall figuring this out
i know this code is good this code is
actually from the gsl
shader cookbook so it's pretty legit
code let me just pull that up so i can
show you guys
gsl cookbook it has tons of info so this
we're going to be using this quite a bit
as it has tons of good stuff
but yeah and here they do have uh
some code for printing these and stuff
like
i use this gets type string function
and i added a few things to it like the
true and false because there's more this
is just kind of an example function
and somewhere in here
yeah here we go the get print active
tribs this is basically what we're using
is this code here for opengl 4.3 and
later
this exact code but in my case it
doesn't work i'm not sure why
i'm i'm willing to bet i'm doing
something wrong but i don't actually
know
because i've checked and checked and
checked and it seems like it's fine
i also did some more searching and tried
some other methods which had
similar problems they seemed to almost
work
but not quite so i left those in here
commented out if anyone wants to
pull this down from github and if they
can figure it out and
push the changes back up i would really
appreciate it it would also help me
figure out what the heck i'm doing wrong
because honestly i don't know uh i could
probably
it's one of those things where you feel
like you could check forever and you'll
never
figure it out but there must be just
like one little problem somewhere that
i'm missing
but in general this should work or maybe
it'll work fine for you maybe it's just
some weird glitch that i'm running into
for
some unknown reason which tends to
happen with programming a lot and one of
the reasons people get frustrated with
it
all right but that is basically it we
have talked about
checking your version of opengl
with this type of code to make sure
you're using the right type
we've talked about making sure you're on
4.3 or later
you can do that with glfw
in these versions do the check and we've
talked about
the new way of uploading our meshes
or mesh data that's more extendable and
easier to manage in the long run because
well rather than uploading it's one
giant chunk you just upload each chunk
individually and they're specifically
bound and named so it's a little easier
to line up with your shaders in the long
run
and uh yeah check the source code down
below oh yeah and also
we uh talked about
querying your attributes so
all right that's pretty much it i've
commented out all the uniform
stuff we're going to talk about uniforms
how to get a list of uniforms and
blocking out your uniforms in the next
episode and also probably some debug
messages
and then from there we should start
being able to actually do
super cool stuff with shaders just want
to make sure we get all the stuff in our
c
plus plus code right before we go full
on
to gsl because at some point here in a
couple episodes we're not even going to
be touching c
plus anymore we're only going to be
editing pretty much
this code all the time and just doing
super cool stuff with shaders from like
particle effects to uh well you name it
so
see in the next episode thanks for
watching math code tech tutorials
over and out